[Música]
decenas de migrantes fallecieron en
aguas del Mediterráneo cerca las costas
italianas cuando la embarcación en la
que intentaban llegar a Europa náufrago
el gobierno italiano liderado por la
primera ministra Georgia meloni prometió
combatir a los traficantes de personas
y vuelve a escalar la violencia entre
Israel y los territorios palestinos en
la jornada de hoy tres personas murieron
en enfrentamientos que podrían paralizar
las conversaciones de paz que comenzaron
en la vecina Jordania
y varias ciudades mexicanas fueron
escenario de manifestaciones ciudadanas
contra la reforma electoral impulsada
por el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador criticada por diferentes
sectores por considerar que reduce la
capacidad la independencia y el
desempeño del INE el Instituto Nacional
electoral
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora vamos a comenzar en Italia
en donde una embarcación que
transportaba a cientos de migrantes de
diferentes nacionalidades naufragó en
aguas del mar Mediterráneo de acuerdo
con los reportes decenas de ellos
fallecieron entre ellos varios menores
de edad la primera ministra italiana
Georgia meloni lamentó este hecho
criticó a los traficantes de personas y
se comprometió a combatirlos de otra
parte
la presidenta de la comisión europea
pidió acelerar la reforma sobre
migración y asilo en el bloque
comunitario
el Mediterráneo nuevamente se convirtió
en el lugar de la muerte para decenas de
migrantes luego de que una embarcación
que transportaba civiles de Afganistán
Irán Pakistán y otros países se
estrellara contra las rocas en las
costas cercanas a la localidad de
calabria dentro de las víctimas se
encontraban niños y al menos 80 personas
lograron sobrevivir La primera ministra
Georgia Melody reaccionó la tragedia y
se comprometió a lidiar con la
inmigración irregular
la primera ministra Georgia expresa su
profundo dolor por las numerosas vidas
truncadas por los traficantes de seres
humanos el gobierno se ha comprometido a
prevenir las salidas y con ellas la
ocurrencia de estas tragedias y seguirá
haciéndolo ante todo exigiendo la máxima
cooperación de los estados de salida y
de origen
la Cruz Roja italiana auxilió a los
sobrevivientes de un nuevo caso que
revive la crisis migratoria en el
Mediterráneo un asunto a tratar para la
comisión Europea
estoy profundamente entristecida por el
Terrible naufragio frente a las costas
de calabria la pérdida resultante de
Vidas de migrantes inocentes es una
tragedia todos juntos debemos redoblar
nuestros esfuerzos En el pacto sobre
migración y asilo y en el plan de acción
sobre el Mediterráneo central la
situación de los migrantes se complicó
más luego de Que el parlamento italiano
aprobara el pasado jueves un decreto que
fija un nuevo procedimiento que
condiciona la labor de los barcos de
salvamento de migrantes a pesar del
rechazo de Naciones Unidas según el
proyecto de migrantes desaparecidos de
la ONU se registraron más de 17.000
muertes y desapariciones en el
Mediterráneo central desde 2014 y
continúan los combates entre las tropas
rusas y ucranianas en las ciudades de
kramators Y bahamut en donde los
ciudadanos se protegen de los combates
en refugios en donde los servicios de
Electricidad de gas y agua funcionan con
deficiencia Aunque mucho mejor que en
semanas anteriores Catalina Gómez Ángel
periodista de France 24 nos da más
información en el siguiente Norte desde
Ucrania
esta oscuridad que ustedes ven a sus
espaldas es la tradicional que se vive
cada noche en la ciudad de kramators la
ciudad actualmente más importante en la
región del control de las fuerzas
ucranianas aún así la realidad es que la
luz y la electricidad se ha recuperado
dentro de las viviendas dicen que es
muchísimo mejor que semanas atrás pero
lo que son las calles viven en completa
oscuridad y la atención en esta región
del donbad Sigue estando en esa ciudad
de bakmuth que lleva estando en disputa
desde el verano pasado cuando las tropas
rusas empezaron un asedio para tomarla
hasta hoy sigue en control de las
fuerzas ucranianas pero lo que nos
cuentan los soldados que están allí es
que la situación ha cambiado rápidamente
en los últimos horas y días las tropas
ucranianas han destruido una Represa en
la parte sur de la ciudad con el río lo
que ha permitido inundar parte de la
ciudad para contener el avance de las
tropas rusas y también cuando se quieren
retirar poderlas atacar con más
facilidad pero lo que también hacen los
rusos es estarla prácticamente
encerrando hoy en día va como Solamente
se puede entrar por una carretera y
temen que si se acercan a ella pues
obviamente queden encerrados esto ha
hecho que algunas unidades o algunas de
las unidades del ejército que están
adentro hayan empezado a retirarse
Aunque ellos dicen que dentro de la
ciudad Siguen con el total control pero
lo que también nos cuentan es la
situación Allí está cambiando
rapidísimamente el presidente había
dicho que la ciudad todavía estaba en
control de ucranianos que ellos iban a
pelear por ellas al final pero que
también iban a evaluar día a día la
situación allí para ver qué pasaría
porque los ucranianos siguen insistiendo
que lo más importante para ellos es
preservar y cuidar a sus hombres vamos a
ir ahora hasta medio oriente allí la
escalada de violencia un ciudadano
palestino asesinó a dos israelíes en
respuesta a un grupo de grupo de
israelíes atacaron en las zonas de
cisjordania en donde dejaron también a
un palestino muerto y a varios heridos y
allí También varias viviendas fueron
incendiadas estos hechos podrían
paralizar las conversaciones de paz
entre israelíes y palestinos que
comenzaron este domingo en Jordania
es un nuevo episodio violento que vuelve
a escalar las tensiones entre israelíes
y palestinos este domingo un palestino
se acercó a un auto en una intersección
de jugara y mató a dos colonos israelíes
a balazos y la respuesta de los
israelíes no tardó en llegar quemaron
casas ocuparon residencias y dejaron Al
menos un muerto y decenas de heridos
algo por lo que hasta el Primer Ministro
de derechas Benjamín annetanyahu tuvo
que llamar a la calma
lo encontraremos lo detendremos y
ajustaremos cuentas con él pidió que
aunque la sangre hierva y los ánimos
Aguascalientes que no tomen la ley en
sus manos
y es que esta atención no viene de la
nada Los menos de dos meses que llevamos
de 2000 a 23 63 palestinos han sido
asesinados en las redadas casi diarias
del gobierno israelí en territorios a
palestinos el presidente de la autoridad
Palestina majuda Baz condenó lo sucedido
y señaló a Israel como responsable el
estado de Palestina condena
enérgicamente el terror racial continuo
de Israel y la guerra abierta contra el
pueblo palestino en todos los niveles
una situación que se da en paralelo a
las conversaciones de paz que comenzaron
este domingo en Jordania un tema
sensible para ambos a bandos no es la
primera vez que se intentan a paralizar
con manifestaciones en contra muchos
palestinos aseguran que estas
conversaciones equivalen a ceder ante la
ocupación
esta reunión patrocinada por Estados
Unidos se celebra Mientras hay masacres
y crímenes cometidos por la ocupación
contra nuestro pueblo
ahora queda por ver si los ataques
aparalizan a los intentos de diálogo y
se retrocede al punto inicial nos vamos
ahora hasta México allí diferentes
ciudades del país fueron escenarios de
masivas movilizaciones contra la reforma
electoral impulsada por el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador una de las
protestas más concurridas fue la que
tuvo lugar en el zócalo de la Ciudad de
México los ciudadanos aseguran que el
polémico Plan B como se le conoce a esta
propuesta del presidente reduce los
recursos humanos y el presupuesto del
Instituto Nacional electoral el INE lo
que afectaría la autonomía y también la
legitimidad de diferentes procesos
electorales como las presidenciales del
2024 Mario carbonel corresponsal de
France 24 nos da más detalles desde la
calle de la capital mexicana
este domingo ciudadanos de la capital
del país y de otros centenar de ciudades
en México y en el extranjero se reúnen a
la convocatoria de más de cien
organizaciones para rechazar las
modificaciones a las leyes electorales
básicamente Salvador porque está usted
Bueno pues han sido muchos años de
construir un sistema electoral
decente y
confiable y
pues nos negamos a que esto se acabe que
lo terminen
por esa es la razón de acuerdo el
presidente López Obrador ha
descalificado esta concentración ha
dicho que Quienes se reúnen en realidad
buscan defender un régimen de
privilegios que son conservadores Marta
qué diría al respecto
el presidente nos ha tratado de
desacreditar
desde que llegó esta muestra y esta
expresión ciudadana confirma lo
contrario no venimos a defender la
corrupción venimos a defender al INE
Muchas gracias esa es el motivo por lo
que se congregan aquí porque consideran
que las reformas debilitan al organismo
electoral y ponen en riesgo la certeza
de las elecciones pero ahora será la
suprema corte de justicia de la nación
la que tome la última palabra para
responder a estas impugnaciones que
buscan frenar estos cambios a la
legislación
[Música]
punto final en las noticias de France 24
siga con nuestra programación
[Música]